Venus one of the most fascinating and
dangerous planets in our solar system
it's filled with scorching temperatures
crushing atmospheric pressure and acid
rain but despite these dangers some
people think it might be a better planet
for humans to settle on than
Mars but
why and would a human settlement on
Venus even be possible
sit back as we take you on a 10,000 day
journey of how Humanity could populate
this
planet yeah
maybe day
one okay okay not so fast before you set
foot on Venus we're going to have to run
some extensive tests and gather more
information about this
planet first we'll need to launch
robotic missions and map it out and
collect information about the
environment luckily we already have a
bit of a head start on this since 1961
spacecraft have been flying by and
profiling Venus these missions measured
things like the topography atmospheric
pressure and overall conditions of the
planet but there's still a lot to learn
about the venutian surface it's been 30
years since the US has gone to Venus
with a mission that's Noam Eisenberg he
works for the Venus exploration analysis
group a NASA Community whose goal is to
keep people updated on new information
about Venus in the 2020s and 2030s gnome
will be part of a satellite mission to
Venus to help us understand and see more
of the planet than ever before but today
gnome's going to help us determine
whether or not colonizing Venus is a
good idea you have to wear one one or
the other of several different science
fiction hats in order to make this
happen okay let's put our hypothetical
science fiction hats to the test and get
started day
500 we've been trying to colonize Venus
for a little over a year now and the
results have been
well there's been a bit of trial and
error going on with our
astronauts they keep going out to
explore the surface of Venus but keep
dying
why so it's it's not clear that if you
were immediately transported there
whether you would burn to death or Crush
to death first but certainly both of
those things would happen before you
affixiated in the carbon dioxide
atmosphere right well we probably should
have listened to g a bit closer because
it turns out the venusian surface is
incredibly
dangerous three reasons why Venus has
one of the hottest surface temperatures
of any Planet even Mercury the surface
temperatures reach
467 de C that's hot enough to melt lead
or some unsuspecting
astronauts but let's say we somehow
manag to build super heat resistant
astronaut suits well you'd still be met
with Incredible pressure the atmospheric
pressure on Venus is equivalent to what
you'd experience at a depth of 900 M
underwater
this would instantly Crush any astronaut
it would also crush and destroy your
spaceship as you land and if you manage
to avoid all that which you won't but
let's say you do you'll also have to
deal with a corrosive atmosphere and
acid rain these conditions are powerful
enough to destroy your equipment and
eventually melt your skin H okay I don't
think this is going to work out let's
jump ahead and try to terrify form Venus
to make it more like Earth in order to
make it to this future we're going to
need a lot of smart programmers so if
you want to be part of this journey well
you better start learning how to code
that's why I've been using the sponsor
of today's video boot. it's like an
online RPG that teaches you programming
skills the platform is full of leveling
up and quests that are designed to get
your writing code and launching as fast
as possible you can also gain experience
in backend development with Python and
go programming languages and if you're
ever stuck you can always check out the
Discord where the community can help you
with any problems best of all if you're
a programmer you can earn some serious
scratch in 2023 the median salary for
back-end developer careers was over 100
Grand and a lot of the time you get to
work from home so click on the link in
the description and use the code what if
to get 25% off your first payment with
boot dodev that can either be for a
month or a full year
instead of reading about it in textbooks
start your coding Journey with boot
dodev day
1000 so we've been attempting to
terraform Venus and it's been a pretty
tricky process the first problem we'd
need to solve would be the atmosphere to
make it similar to what we have on Earth
we'd need to eliminate the carbon
dioxide and sulfuric clouds in theory we
could introduce genetically engineered
microorganisms that absorb carbon
dioxide but then there's the scorching
temperature on Venus now solving this
could be done in multiple ways one of
them involves setting up solar Shades in
space this would redirect the sun's Rays
so they don't hit Venus which would
reduce the solar radiation and cool the
planet over
time this all sounds wicked cool from a
science fiction perspective but
realistically we're a couple hundred or
thousands of years too early for any of
this to be
possible okay this is really complicated
gnome any ideas the only way we could
inhabit the surface of Venus is if we
changed Venus to be much more earthlike
than it is and right now we don't have
that technology we don't have that
ability we don't have the resources if
we could terraform Venus it'd be much
much easier to sort of Reet terraform
Earth and undo all the dam Dage we've
done here and and I don't even know how
you would go about doing that think
about that as science fiction you know
science fantasy method right okay sounds
like we should switch our tactics if
humans were to live on Venus well it
technically couldn't be on the surface
that would just cost too much money time
and Technology that's not available yet
maybe it's not about living on the
surface but instead living right above
it let's fast forward
day
2500 okay after years of experimentation
we've finally found the answer about how
to live on Venus I think the new plan is
to create a cloud city 50 km above
Venus's surface arguably this could be
one of the most comfortable places for
humans to exist in our solar system
besides Earth that uh altitude in the
Venus atmosphere is kind of actually the
most earthlike any other place in the
solar system is so in that altitude the
temperature is around depending on where
you are is somewhere between 20 and 30°
C so it could be shirt sleeve weather
the atmospheric pressure is around one
bar half to one bar so up here in the
clouds it would feel like a nice summer
day and the atmospheric pressure
wouldn't Crush you sounds good to me but
what would you live in
exactly Well we'd create blimps made of
keflon that could be suspended in the
clouds each blimp could have a different
purpose and have different groups of
people within it all connected with
covered bridges so you can travel from
one end to the other we'd also be
protected from any harmful solar
radiation due to Venus's thick
atmosphere that's something Mars can't
provide but despite us making
significant progress these Cloud cities
wouldn't be without their
shortcomings day 5000
okay we've been expanding and living in
these Cloud colonies for over 6 years
now we should also mention that you and
your space colleagues have been working
a
ton hey we never said building a new
population on an entirely different
planet would be easy if you're going to
be one of the people in charge of
colonizing Venus you can expect nonstop
work days from researching the planet to
just setting things up for your daily
life and in
survival you'd need to build Cloud ships
that can provide food through hydroponic
gardening and solar paneled ships that
can provide Power this would require an
incredible amount of skill and
resources and oops I forgot to mention
another extremely dangerous thing that
you need to be aware of that's the
sulfuric acid
clouds they're going to be tricky to
avoid even being 50 km above the surface
remember these things are hazardous and
could easily melt your skin now not all
areas In This Cloud City would have
these clouds luckily but if you are
living in an area where that sulfuric
acid is there then you have you're
talking about a keplar envelope you're
talking about things that you need much
more protection from even if temperature
pressure is not the major concern and
the problems might get even worse as we
progress to our next phase in populating
ven Venus day
10,000 okay we've been populating Venus
for nearly 30 years now hundreds of
astronauts have come and gone some have
even started having children creating
new generations of native
venutian you've kept busy maintaining
and building these Cloud ships while
learning more about the planet but over
the decades you've been here life hasn't
been nearly as exciting as you thought
it might be
you spend most of your time in this
yellow Haze maybe you get to see some
sky and stuff like that so not
necessarily the most uh romantic or
inspirational location so uh you're
living in a box and most of your view of
the surface will be through you know
automated ports and stuff like that and
thanks to the acid clouds it's likely
you wouldn't be able to spend much time
outside either not the most comfortable
environment to live in in either the
atmosphere or the surface
H living in these Cloud ships doesn't
sound all that great sure you'd be
creating a new world for humans to live
in but it wouldn't be much exploring it
would just be going from ship to ship
maintaining them and getting to research
a surface that's 50 km below you sounds
like a tiring and somewhat sad
existence would it be worth it so for
like permanent habitation in or on or
around Venus I don't think will happen I
don't think it should happen but that
doesn't mean our hopes for humans
becoming an Interstellar civilization
are
misguided but I do think that permanent
habitation outside of Earth both should
and will happen I I believe that you
know in the long term multi-century long
term getting all the eggs out of the one
basket getting all the humans off of
Earth is what we need to do as a species
in order to ensure our you know in
perpetuity survival
so maybe populating Venus isn't the best
idea after all it's impractical in many
ways impossible and seems like a sad
existence for humans
anyway want to suggest what planet we go
to next well check out our patreon where
you can get frontof thee line access to
suggest and vote on the next stories we
cover maybe one of you will suggest
living on Mars to see how that
goes but that sounds like a story for
another what
if